that is the difference between 2014 and
19 well I would say that now the
organisation of Elections is not and
must not be the business as usual and
when I met in April after Cambridge
analytical case the electoral
commissioners from all the Member States
we had a good debate but it was quite
clear that there was not enough
understanding that now the situation is
much more complex that we have to be
more careful about data protection about
protection against foreign propaganda
that we have to be much more resilient
against cybercrime and that the
situation now needs to be much more
careful and more mobilized to protect
the free elections in principle what we
want and what we want to achieve our
four things to protect the people
against the manipulation and make sure
that the private data will not be stolen
and abused here again I have to make a
clear link to Cambridge analytic a case
where this has been proven that this
happened to our people also in Europe
the second thing online political
advertising which is on the rise we have
figures which show that more and more
the political parties are advertising
online so it must be transparent
including the funding and in fact what
we say is that the rules which apply
offline must also apply online the third
thing we want the elections to be
protected against cyber crime and cyber
attacks and the fourth thing we want the
European people to be more resilient
towards this information and propaganda
which means to actively fight against
this information without introducing any
kind of censorship this was our aim how
do we want to do this of course this way
law the success of this will be very
much dependent on a good cooperation
with the Member States and on the
efficient action on the site of the
Member States
that's why we are recommending them to
pay proper attention to the elections
from all those aspects which I outlined
a minute before and we also want to
coordinate and communicate and have a
proper dialogue on the European level so
we ask the Member States to give us the
contact points for such communication we
plan to have two meetings one in January
and one in April next year I myself and
my colleagues and the Commission we find
ourselves quite authorized to to do that
and to invite the Member States for such
common work because we studied very
thoroughly what happened under the
Facebook Cambridge analytical case now
we see what are the risk and threats and
I think that it's the proper thing to
share this knowledge with the Member
States and to mobilize our powers
because we are a kind of insight the
topic of security I am available for
your questions if you want to ask
something about the strengths and rules
for anti money laundering
on European Public Prosecutor's Office
which should in the future if we have
unanimous consent of the Member States
deal also with terrorist criminal
offences and of course also the new
proposed or to delete terrorist content
from online sphere but my colleague joy
okay thank you very much thank you watch
Commissioner Commissioner is a real
problem which requires urgent action
every single one of the attacks in
Europe over the last 18 months or so had
an online dimension either through
incitement to carry out an attack
sometimes instructions on how to do it
and often glorification afterwards
and terrorists content is a to present
on too many platforms Europol are
working with more than 150 platforms in
trying to tackle terrorist content
online the UK home office did a study
last year and they found that - and
their supporters were using more than
400 platforms to push out this material
and there's been a shift in the nature
of the attacks that we've been facing we
discussed that here before we've been
facing more so-called lone actor attacks
and I'm afraid that too often the people
who are carrying out those attacks have
been radicalized by exposure to online
content there's a recent case in France
where an individual was radicalized
after sitting alone in his bedroom
watching hours and hours of video to the
point where he rejected his family his
friends his previous values and sought
to carry out an attack fortunately in
that case the French authorities got to
him before he was able to do so and the
potential damage caused by this
terrorist content Rises dramatically
every hour
it remains online as it spreads from
platform to platform three-quarters of
all the links to - sponsored content are
shared within four hours of release so
what are we proposing to do what are you
proposing today that is different we are
proposing to create three new
obligations first a new instrument a new
legal instrument removal orders we're
making it mandatory for platforms to act
within one hour when they receive a
removal order from the police or
judicial authorities and take the
material in question down secondly if
you're a platform if your platform is
being used to spread terrorist content
then you will have an obligation to make
use of proactive proactive measures to
detect
and prevent it from either being
uploaded in the first place or
reappearing and third an obligation on
the member states that the member states
need to have a dedicated law enforcement
capacity in place with the resources to
effectively detect terrorist content and
to issue removal orders now none of this
is anywhere near censorship we're not
talking about some gray area of
difficult judgement Terrace content
material that incites or advocates
committing terrorist acts promotes or
glorifies a terrorist group or provides
instruction in how to carry out an
attack is illegal it's illegal online
just as it is illegal offline and it
needs to be removed even so we will make
sure that there are robust safeguards in
place with clear rules about
transparency and effective complaint
mechanisms and the provision for
judicial recourse if necessary and while
we expect the vast majority of platforms
will will cooperate we do need effective
sanctions and that's why we will work
with the Member States to establish a
system of sanctions and in the case of
systematic failure to comply with
removal orders I mean not just once but
repeatedly then there is a provision for
hosting service providers to be fined up
to four percent of their global turnover
the terrorist content online is as Veera
was just saying one part of a spectrum
of cyber and cyber enabled threats that
we face and the other important theme
that we're talking about today is
measures to reinforce the security of
our electoral processes as Vera's just
said our elections indeed our democratic
institutions
have been targeted there are established
cases where they have been targeted
through hacks leaks fake news and the
misuse of mind personal data and so we
need to take action to better protect
against cyber attacks against
disinformation and to protect personal
data Vera was talking particular about
data Maria will say a bit more about
some of the other challenges but
together we are taking a series of
measures to reinforce our cyber security
and resilience to tackle disinformation
and fake news and to reinforce the rules
around personal data and we want in view
of the European elections and indeed the
national elections that are coming up in
the months ahead
all of the actors to work together so
that we are proposing the Member States
create election cooperation networks to
work on these issues and in addition to
the meetings that Vera mentioned we will
be organizing a high-level conference
here in Brussels next month October the
middle of October to bring together
experts and decision-makers from across
the Union and beyond to identify
concrete ways to prevent cyber and cyber
enabled threats to our elections thank
you very much illegal terrorists very
tablet travaille they keep present on
can't imagine concentration on a spec is
read receiver security the Borobudur
applicant am the cyber security amity
are the cybersecurity news even
undeniably nevada prague defeat des any
malicious who saw accelerate the
pureness of Nevada said Salma Melanie de
enero de septiembre news even present a
no true proposition
Cantor enforce Ahmad Ahmad adolescence
Anissa encanta la creación de certain
system the certification
sumit mmm Astra's vu
premiere three log of a polymer you can
say no seven Clermont recommand
announced on kappa de rossi yo show de
la proposition canoe phase on a Tampa a
neva who's Rudy novo dream pass fair
pass a nosy for an evil superior Aaron
for Scylla cybersecurity Dulhaniya hopin
he still a reason for local origin no
present on the Volvo de ba la creación
de results on through the competence
Amity a deceiver security and hope Allah
Christendom son of a pea the competence
the bow ephod real sister up in the
context expertise experience Dom
disposal on Europe aletan Daniela me
Audrey new Diwali Metro novel affarin
sorta do cheer a the beneficence Doucet
experience supports Allah cannot propose
own Cotulla dr. de la severe security
and hope mr. own country Don Lorenzo in
C resembling savoir faire opieop damo
disposal and c la vision sera pillow t /
insulting the coordination Nachiketa mom
kiwi participar
a la creación de su Rizzo razzo Rabia
kiss votre
in community Talon the competence da
cunha sauce it is on TT Kapoor said a
competin special is a material the
cybersecurity de fête salon mapping
effective a par la camisa Robin Ilya
deserved assistance wasn't an TT dont't
renew Kieran please the condition
porridge want Cerezo beaucoup doses on
today under a postulate birthdays
participate not reproach a pilot del
caño Laveau a no se que dou T dou sank a
millon de ho Supraja pilot Deborah on
novembre ensuite Lizzie for Julian
demotion a reservoir enforce a
Parrinello McClellan atre proposition
universal to the competence European
said structure kirisame loja salon not
repetition a brussels discretion
supports ironically colleges data on
Virenque trova effective DC DeMille
Ventura mobile is rod to the resource
disponible on bonuses sure
Aloha prendre supplies the leader manual
Amity of the civil security the resource
listen to the competitors beyond Ranji
program digital europe canoes even
propose a a mini EDA program the rogers
horizon europe the new proposed uncle is
it Imam Razi initiative a contribute or
BG global doesn't look good the turn the
cutter Amelia Yoho
when you knew the written pala ill
indispensable callus on through the
competence of a pea pistou secant a a
become partner here so lead Ave Clement
privy sip aqua new share some active mo
the zombies dismantle industry a dough
true partner prevail
Susan considered direction composite the
representant is it among a doula
Commission result of a coordinated
activity Eva fiancée on parties Rizzo
and secret took like immunity the
competence uncuff lose important loose
and Finance Radha Crusader research
innovation and secure the project deploy
amounted technology
alpha loosened Sarang capacity to
mobilize EDA Mirsky oblique also no per
her ability lip ridiculous on through
the competence of repair sue tiandra
party the do minivan Tia want and
rubella who shares the diploma
LS the first trip to your communion you
could tell our search result privilege
radically show the novel method the
Crypt are resistant memos ordinate
County the future one called approach a
visible develop a letter object
connected the Diploma new Sibley room
the proceed experimentation is also near
Lisandro trees Keisha integral a novel
technology receiver security download
Roderick Yaffa concern Alexandra
structure calm in the zone through the
competence rupiah
finish ah arisu security the
communication and release authority desi
tamam unka in Bastogne a universal do
vulnerability dollars ECL kisser hey
with Chile accessible for two treasures
to leisure sir
and second volley voy a la structure
Cano proposal Chaudhary
permit in Maya coordination a
collaboration
Parmalee difference actor Vlasov are
security and hope not Ram vision I do do
tell you open the capacity industrial
technological around foresee a duly
permit de l'avenir do keep in place the
premier plan the only solution the cedar
security the processor and ashram in
Arvada not sovereignty numeric now see
mister before going to your questions
will be just remind you of the press
material as Empress material out there
already since yesterday will be
published and also outside and now let's
go to your questions if you could please
introduce yourself as usual and also as
to which of the three commissioners you
I'm Patti Smith Irish Times and
commissioner King really I think you're
probably the person I want to ask a
question two questions one one is a it's
simply a technical question about the
how the takedown operation will take
place you say that the hours from
notification is it proposed that certain
bodies will be given a specific power to
notify in other words not just me
ringing up Facebook and saying you
should take this down is it proposed
that that specific bodies would have
that power and secondly if this this is
a proposal for legislation given the way
the European Union works it's extremely
unlikely that the legislation will get
through before the European elections
next year or you know within a
reasonable space of time have you any
indication from the online companies
that they would be willing to operate a
system like this on a voluntary basis
pending the implementation of the
legislation so first of all half step
back we're not starting from zero on
this there is an established framework
of voluntary cooperation at the moment
which has got us to a certain point and
that will continue what we're saying is
that we need to go further and these are
the concrete measures that we are
proposing in as you say a piece of
legislation at the removal order a new
instrument that will require action when
it is served upon a platform will be
served by law enforcement or judicial
authorities in a Member State on the
timing what we need to go fast on this
so we are putting this down now in the
hope expectation that working with the
European Parliament and working with the
council we can get an agreement in this
mandate before the elections and we've
set quite a short period for coming in
to
force of six months so we really do need
to get on with this we're responding not
only to invitations to work harder on
this subject from from various law
enforcement authorities but also to
calls that have come from different
governments in the council and indeed
from the European Parliament so I hope
that they will work with us to get this
done fast
Costigan's German astronomer of a potato
co commissioner King piscis a concern
with terrorism apropos vote for Jeb
blossom and a horizontal hop disposer de
la regla Montezuma preserve a visible
motto enforcement area fairy Simone
Center affair
en GOP bar de ferran filial Estonian
Estonian rebound annuals a mantra curry
control et appear on those in Syria to
be small low-key to be bomb on our
example coupons million the transaction
code again Eng physical controls Tetris
Alicia don't do DiMaggio Papa Zita ssme
como Hotel Velma PK cannot hotel control
is or to Posca to control organza pearly
bunkered ma'am
prefer to take on bunker me in jail well
we are gradually strengthening the
framework
practice on anti-money laundering where
we achieved a lot of progress and now we
want the member states to implement them
especially the for Santi money
laundering in full and now in the recent
proposal we also needed to address the
weaknesses which are in the and that
supervisory framework so this is exactly
what we adopted this this week and as
you said these are also the really
reactions on the revelations about you
are to stand and dance can some other
banks so we are trying to get rid of the
loopholes because the criminals
operating in international sphere they
they love loopholes and of course they
are not mistaken finding them so we want
the member states to do their job in
supervising the
the suspicious transactions and
suspicious people if I can simply find
like that these rules are foreseen in
our anti money laundering legislation as
you know that we adopted v Santa money
laundering directive which will come
into force at the beginning of 2020 and
here we are strengthening transparency
we are making the final beneficiaries
registers fully public we are
strengthening the rules of transparency
for trust
we are also covering the cyber
currencies we are inviting other oblige
entities other than banks to cooperate
with the financial investigation units
at the member state level and as I said
these are all very useful things but
they have to be applied and fully done
in practice so we are pushing the Member
States to to do better we are now
running 40 16 infringement procedures as
for the force anti-money laundering
directive and we are in constant
dialogue member states because our our
aim is not to organize the infringement
procedures our aim is to have the
bulletproof system in the EU and coming
back to this week's proposal this is
focused on strengthening of the European
Banking Authority which with its powers
and staff the European Banking Authority
will become the lead agency when it
comes to the prevention and management
of the anti money laundering
risks and of course again a very strong
cooperation with the Member States is
foreseen to understand the strengths and
competence it's important to stress that
in case of some failures at the level of
the Member State as a last resort
there is the new competence for the epi'
to act and you asked about how we are
monitoring the situation in the Member
States for the first time the
European Banking Authority saw doing the
thorough analysis on what happened in
case of pilotos Bank so we are using all
the straw man
there is a security way together There
is obviously a link to there's also a
terrorist dimension even if what we've
seen recently are a spate of so-called
don't like the term or low-cost attacks
there is still funding involved in
terrorism and following the money is one
of the proven effective ways of trying
to unpick terrorist plots and if the
worst happens finding the perpetrators
so some of the elements that Vera's just
mentioned are very important from a
security point of view law enforcement
access to financial information and
effective cooperation between financial
intelligence units across Europe so that
we use that financial intelligence to go
after serious and organized criminals
and on some occasions terrorists we need
to implement what's been agreed we also
need to look to see whether there's more
that needs to be done and that's
something that we'll be discussing in
the in the weeks ahead I just note that
in the u.s. they have a system for
tracking terrorist finance that is more
effective than what we are able to do at
the moment in Europe and I think for me
there's a question about whether we need
to to look whether there are some
lessons we can learn from the way the
u.s. use financial intelligence to
tackle some security challenges
thank you very much so next released via
Tennessee
other nights with CNA back in the Cold
War era were things were a little bit
more clear Katherine with you who the
enemy was and who was interfering with
electoral processes there was always
there is let's say retaliatory capacity
of the West should the EU build such a
capacity in the modern let's say
information warfare era because some are
you some security experts argue that
what happened the Cold War was there was
a deterrence because the West had nukes
as well was not only the East ahead
nukes and at some point when they
realized danger they started talking to
each other but in this case some would
argue that the West we don't have a
let's say information warfare deterrence
capacity right now and the other side
has nothing to talk about with us so
certainly you built as a capacity and if
so did you ever consider even your
pursue for these proposals you're
proposing today thanks totality and code
war from the perspective of our civic
regime and Maria and congratulations she
is too young so I will I will try to
reply of course this is the new kind of
war which is now running through the
digital sphere at the fact that it's in
the digital world it doesn't mean that
it doesn't post big risk to the real
world so these roads are very very much
an in this case painfully interconnected
I remember very well the doctrine of the
totalitarian Soviet Union propaganda and
it was you must know who your enemies
and the second was an icing is our last
big here 100 times repeated
is true becomes a true and we don't want
to use these instruments I think that
it's important to clarify what we stand
for and be more concrete about where we
see our enemies the enemies for me are
those who will celebrate if we will fail
in Europe also in case of the next
year's election and we have to fight
against lying which is not illegal by
telling the people the truth I don't
have any butter recipe and we have to be
coherent and we have to say this clearly
to the people in Europe and ask them for
cooperation to engage more critical
thinking and to be more resilient
against the propagandist waves and
pressures which which are being imposed
on them through online and of course
this is in one package why I have my
first instinct after what I heard about
Cambridge analytic a case i exactly felt
like in the 8th 1988 and i realized well
what about the elections in my country
they are there is no way for free choice
of people it was brainwashing it was
permanent propaganda it was the pressure
I wanted to go where I plan to go to
United Kingdom in 1986 it was as if now
I want to go to Mars and that there was
a person who was spying me in the
corridor of in my house and he told me
that after two years when he got drunk
under the Christmas tree he told me do
you know two years ago I was spying you
I knew everything about you
so these were the methods of the
Communists or those days communists and
totalitarian regime how far are we now
now we use similar methods by means of
fantastic new modern technologies I
don't think we should be
if you have to stop or diminish the
impact of and this is pretty dangerous
so that's why we are doing what we are
doing
thank you very much related to add
something see Sherlock is John Doe I can
declare do some seaberries he was a
volleyball a detective nice not a
directive in salute Nachiketa mama keep
a really terrible mo and to detect on
Katra I said repair apartment
I'll see to repeal not true proposition
Dava a modern force a doula shows any
sake l Alex participe as he still is it
amount of the rapid Melissa day a
remedial vulnerability news open
government proposal from a blueprint a
mechanism of the coordination a hoppin
on Kat attack a larger shell in new
servo so novel see proposal a creation
the story so the sound through the
competence grass supership you lot
kisora mesa miss another an ovum eleven
kazanka fast at the defeat in european
continue an important project
the service was evanka in certain
dependence the for Mesa na na repair
make a momento new disposal in expertise
new dispose and inexperienced digital
assistants result organization his own
Kiki Sola avec leur expertise no Raj
Alonso edit transform a set expertise at
experienced improvi a service
commercializable
d'Ivoire luna rubin keepo recovery lanza
modulation de valor de la severe
security a Portola info dojos Jinpa Roma
de a la fragmentation actual Kelley
different communities parla SE hace busy
LaDonna proposition seola selection le
so to reach a national case on shards
election Judy ray Anna lab want a bump
of our discreet a avec les auto
technicians answered la protección de
Donnie
even prove our core danila la acción a
doe trooper in the folk blues invest is
man I suppose silicon proposal assault
los entre el v the Roma DEA
asset cooperation cadet ran for sale
until a different community
community Durocher lndustry juice co
demacian civil-military yes we do Ramadi
allen st deployed invest a small condo
proposed ankylosing travas VL Amazon of
Deena's mom little Capri view dollar
program digital Europe banker low
horizon horizon Europe no Japan's depe
concrescence on Sophie Neveu
ephod recon team it dances directionless
do cooperation please discharge dudeney
please do her PDT date relevant Katra
Sergio Sergio said yo for silicones
entre Lizzie tomorrow
Rizzo mekinese McHale condiment no
sabemos caller reported LeClair it Larry
declare efficacy ridic mo d'Ivoire the
McVicker mechanism
keeper metas cassette corporation so
Africa's
you first
you
Yuriko Deutsche Welle to understand what
you are proposing on the elections
because as I understand it's mostly
about the national authorities so to
understand what the Commission is
concretely proposing is first of all to
facilitate the dialogue and cooperation
between the national authorities and the
second one to create this center of
competence and that network of central
competences are those only these two
measures or didn't understand you
correctly I'm asking on Elections Thank
You member states should send contact
point
it's on them how to this who will be
assigned to this to this come on work as
I said before there are four aspects
data protection political advertising
and funding cyber security and the
forces fight against propaganda and it's
all these things are on the Member
States to manage but we are convinced
that it's good to cooperate on these
matters at on European level and that we
have a lot of good information to share
so at this moment we want to mobilize
the attention of the member states who
are exclusively responsible for
organizing the the elections and to come
to a common understanding and common
plan how to prevent our elections
against these these negative risks or
these negative developments the second
is Maria another thing merci Vera Vera
insisted Sheila protection Denis Citra
Claire
not from s Ursula transparent
transparence la publicity politic CEO Co
not retrieve a holidays informational in
Surah Al Queda Cielo fandom our local do
Conde - Raquel no travel on a plane or
through communication on one a model
real mr. Horizonte don't sue so do girls
exam Sheila transparence Ella proteases
protection the donee
develop or not resuscitate democratic to
see repercussions
direct loss casona par expect $1
proposition le Claremont D si la
protección de Navarre see Lily party
News News some pecan for may use
excisions so immoral in amano-san poor
some paraplegic global annual
in Rampal oppose Rampal a possibility do
post will appear on Finance more open or
lanique history Lamont no clue massage
it correctly formula protection danila
transfer House approval permit and a bar
and for me home on Mondays election
Susan develop non-negotiable
it's still about elections but do you
think that these measures are enough
because basically our recommendations
and also about the the amendment to the
political parties it's only at European
level and this sanction that they cannot
ask for you funding will be for the year
the next year so basically after the
European elections so basically the only
very stringent EU low its GDP are there
are not really very strong safeguards
put in place with these measures for the
sphere of elections the EU doesn't have
competence to legislate so that's why we
use the instrument of communication and
recommendation we would do it anyway
even if we if we have two competitors
because time is running and we have now
250 days before the elections so we had
to hurry up and we came to the propose
of which I'm convinced is necessary and
proportionate so this is this was all we
could do I hope it will work in practice
for the European elections but also as
you indicated for the national elections
so I think that the Member States could
also take a lesson from what was
happening before a British referendum or
in the United States and to be more
resilient when it comes to their
national elections this is again I have
to repeat exclusive competence of the
state thank you very much a couple of
more
although had a dozen phone come I guess
this goes out to mr. King on behalf of
the terrorists content deletion I was
wondering what will happen to small
businesses that maybe not that may not
have the capabilities to have to provide
a 24/7 service and will not be able to
react within one hour after our removal
inquiry has reached them
system of all platforms it's not just
the big platforms that are used to try
and traffic this kind of online
terrorist content that's why we want to
make sure that the one hour requirement
is following being served by law
enforcement or judicial authorities with
with the removal order it's the law
enforcement and judicial authorities
that have taken the judgment about the
content and the platform whatever size
it is even if it's one-man operation
will be bound to react and they can
react because we're not asking them in
those circumstances unlike some other
circumstances to run any difficult
processes or reach separate judgments
according to their own rules and their
own code of conduct they are receiving a
legal order from law enforcement because
that's rather a a strong measure we are
putting in place very strong safeguards
so that if there is a problem then there
is a complaint mechanism and it's all
done in in full transparency so that's
part of the answer the other part of the
answer is that we need to help platforms
of all sizes to be equipped to run
proactive measures if they need to run
proactive measures and there again it's
important that public-private
cooperation in this field as in the
field of cybersecurity is reinforced to
develop the tools and to make them
freely available the big platforms have
made a commitment to share some of their
expertise with the small platforms some
member states it happens the UK is one
of them have developed tools that they
are making available for free and
Europol is increasingly a center of
excellence in dealing with this
challenge and it also is making its
services available for free so we're not
leaving anybody on their own we are
providing a framework and the support
that they will need to follow what we're
setting out in this proposed legislation
I wanted to add that you know that for
more than two years we are promoting the
voluntary action and under the code of
conduct and that not forum we have
thought the biggest companies we have
the actress which cover around 93 94
percent of the market in the EU but what
about the remaining ones and for
terrorist content we simply could not
effort to leave this loophole and that's
why by this legislation we are covering
all the companies all the platforms and
we will continue the voluntary actions
or activities so for the other kinds of
ethical content may no demondo you so to
reach a loss given the Modi DiMaggio
practice the program called a capacity
economic or operational for me serve the
CRVs decade a fascist amount DVT the
risk supplement air we are not really
more Lee platform Lizabeth of the
service mmm
improve our Faribault and well surely
difficulties in akhirah called since you
know Cassio key fortress easier
miserable cat Darla proposition was a
vom be imprisoned consideration set
specificity
repeated platform down a recommendation
the mazurka dotted miss on plastic is on
proactive we electrician can't low
capacity economic cooperation
yes please
hello my name is Dennis tiny friend from
Bulgaria newspaper capital I have a
particular question for Commissioner
Commissioner Gabriel several few years
ago the Central Election Commission in
Bulgaria was attacked by hackers so it's
service were blocked and the Commission
wasn't wasn't able to publish the
election results I just wonder what how
the new proposals for cooperation were
gonna prevent such things happening
again or how they were gonna help you
know authorities deal with the situation
like that and second Bulgarian
authorities then turned for helpful to
the American FBI not to do any European
Authority is it how your proposals were
going to change the situation
we serve your over mrs. COC done not row
proposition Navin part on juice the
proposition de jour de la camisa rebrova
Yana play killer un groupe de travail
the coordination yet Susan Desiree knee
Oh madam ours Vaz de pavo present a
ahaha Apatow the guidance of our system
also premier contraceptive the risk pop
of our anticipate Lili reaction we sow
travail ET encore un groupe de
coordination elisa tomorrow plan lapa
Montano road village emotional pain
Kieran foresee a level a cooperation
I found a true pure PD Pacifica's las
cosas team the situation to produce
you got any further questions that is
not the case and thank you very much for
attending the press conference
you
you